where does this all go what's what's the
what's well it's really simple it's like
when you're getting emails
trying to convince you to play golf or
get the president to play golf
with the prime minister of malaysia
who's under investigation for
manhandling this deal i mean he was the
guy in charge of the sovereign wealth
bucks stops with him you know and his
stepson is the guy for red granite
pictures that greenlit
wolf of wall street you're in a
situation where you're then
i mean it looks like quit broke
arrangements and you're close enough to
the president to influence that and
they're interesting
doing money through your business what
would you call that whoa
business like usually yeah i'm not the
one
to determine that the law law and order
right laws
is the place to determine that so what
do you think's gonna happen what is what
like i think
there are several ongoing depositions
and inquiries that
people don't know about that no one has
looked at glo that all of this has been
a distraction
what has been a distraction sorry it
cost um
i figure if the president can say it on
live tv you can say it on youtube no
youtube's brutal man
so uh no i continue well i'm just saying
i don't know what's gonna happen but i
know several people who are currently
under investigation and who are talking
and or they're witnesses and they're
talking off the record and this will all
come to a head soon and it happened
a long time ago you know what's what's
are you talking about compromised people
in the u.s i don't know
it's ongoing investigation i don't want
to speculate based of
i don't want to get killed probably you
know so but but this
when you when you mention there are
people like you said 100 people at
harvard
i mean that's what the list says we
don't know if that's a sure sure it's
being manipulated you know
is this like his there was people that
you asked about harvard because somebody
was sent back from from harvard i think
it was two people at home more than one
yeah and actually
they were associated with something
interesting
do you guys know about that maybe we
shouldn't get into that the chinese
program yeah the thousand
whatever it's called what's it called
that's that's well known like the
thousand talents program yeah a thousand
pounds
yeah well yeah there's more to it but
there's a little bit more to it
neural nets testing and a lot of that
yeah what is this what is it
go look at what harvard's working on
with bio engineering so check it out
i know that earlier in the year mike
pompeo said we've been infiltrated by
the chinese at every level yep every
level and then we've had repeated
investigations into university
professors
who uh were double dipping china was
paying them
while they were also getting grants from
the us which is illegal call it spying
or
whatever that's compromised you're
coming right right right yeah yeah
you're coming
is this the worst thing about it we have
people in the u.s that have like
there's leverage against them from
foreign interests is that it
i mean the scale is probably the worst
thing i think the scale is
absolutely the worst thing and the scale
meaning
like the chinese can print infinite
money and they got a lot of people yep
so that's it but what so they can keep
compromising people
so you can have 55 000 spies in the u.s
and that's nothing and how many spies do
we have in china
not as many right yeah so
we're compromised from the top down yeah
is that the gist of it uh i've been told
and i obviously can't confirm this that
our gis system is compromised
what is gis it's a global positioning
system okay but it's not gps it's uh
how you keep the map from changing we'll
say i'm pretty sure everything you're
saying
first of all i will be completely honest
it's hard to follow yeah of course it is
there's a purpose yeah i mean yeah we
are really close to it and we've been
looking at it for a really long
time now so that's why we're trying to
do our best to like break it down into
bite-sized videos and starting with very
specific
people and then hopefully and we just
you won't be dead before you get to the
finals
and we just told you that the um and
you'll see in our second part it doesn't
get into all this all we do in our
second part is prove the documents or at
least
the narrowly defined documents we're
looking at in that video are real by
going to a vendor
and they're like yeah we don't know how
they got a hold of that that's not
that's we didn't give it to him
which is weird so the the challenge is
with stories like this
there's so many pieces that need to be
broken down individually before you can
fully understand why
other outlets are corroborating or
reporting so like for instance
we need to know what a sovereign wealth
fund i believe yes we don't know what
that is well you're an idiot if you
don't know what that is because
oh really yeah because the government
you guys should be talking about this
every day because
it's it's the upper echelons of the
government ripping off its people
all right the highest level that's why
those smart people make money
yeah and people get in the streets and
fight about bs when they should be
looking at their own government
there's there's a lot a lot of
distractions being put out into
the media right now and you know it's
not you know people are eating it up and
it does
take people's attention away from this
circuses yeah
yeah possibly but they amplify the bad
actors amplify these simplified
dog do messages you know it's like
america can't
seem to understand anything beyond red
versus blue or this team versus that
team they got to have two and if there's
more than two options they get really
confused and it's that's the neediest
very true
so that's what we're trying to change is
that things are complicated and if you
don't care
fine go watch the kardashians oh wait
you can't we
there's a pandemic and nothing's on tv
we don't we don't we we have
journalism in this country has been
whittled down to a dry
burnt husk rotting in the corner so much
though that we've been accused of being
intelligence agents by steptoe which is
brody's
very high-priced law firm and also
jeffrey epstein's law firm do you want
me to read that letter it's pretty funny
what they called you spies
on election day oh we got an election
day
interesting they're called agents uh
agents agents
accusing you of being government how did
you not get this email was addressed to
yourself
i know it has you oh you do know it's
actually addressed to you it just says
dear mr poor are you saying i'm being
accused of being a spy
well no no no you're not you're not you
know they thought they could reason with
you but
obviously i don't i don't have anything
to do with the editorial work of
you saying this yeah it's true
you need to make that really clear to
these people that's why i'm like wow you
guys got an email like it's to you like
something about it they sent two this
was the this was the one after i asked
them what first they sent me an email
saying
to you actually but it's me cc
and we did not obviously ccu on the
email we just sent it out from our
scanner account so they
created a new chain that one basically
said you are working with stolen
documents from the qatari government i
don't even know what they're talking
about
they said yeah i mean i have it up but
um it basically
uh they accused us of uh working
with qatari-backed hackers let's see
okay is that it hang on it says that's
very long letter
oh it is a long letter but i'll cut to
the chase uh as a result we have reasons
to suspect you are in direct contact and
receiving stolen and potentially
doctored materials from
individuals directly involved with the
qatari sponsored hackers as an example
of the pair relying on these sources the
suggestion that you
that any sales were made to nigeria as
you suggest your questions is false so
people should go watch the video and see
like what
we're actually talking about me no no
he's saying that no
we i mean i love were you working with
me yeah i know
that was addressed to me i'm like what's
addressed to you but
that's the thing i think they're trying
to get you to kill this yeah they're
trying to get you know
the story oh he's not going to give him
i'll give the story more money okay
anyway so this is verifiably untrue the
fact that we're
uh uh in direct contact yeah what
already sponsored hackers there's
nothing to do it sounds pretty cool
uh we can get our we can get our things
without without
having yeah we don't need that that's
the thing we're uh we're learning a lot
of new
skills by the way i think that's why
they think we're we learn to code
i'll tell you this is a big problem
probably for international elites
dealing with like
uh gutter crust like me from the south
side of chicago who's like
i don't know what you're talking about
dude uh you know like you you can't
email me and send me these things
thinking i'm gonna do anything about
what you guys well you won't even
sorry you won't even see it well they
i know about the i know they sent the
emails and i just immediately just
click it and close it and delete i'm
like i don't care i'm not gonna read it
but there's nothing
hear that step don't waste your time
don't waste time
man because i didn't even know what you
guys were working on i'm just like oh
those crazy crazy kids getting accused
of being spies again uh-oh
yeah you want to read that part of the
name oh yeah so this was
tweeted at them documents and i'm like
are these real these fake please help
and no response i get a response from
steptoe
emily read from it she cc'd then we get
this response dear mr pool
this i don't know how they keep doing
this and this time they took emily off
which yeah they're not happy about it
she told them she wasn't happy but the
firm represents this firm represents
elliot brody which we know
which which your agents have disclosed
is the subject of a quote
quote story being prepared for
publication on your youtube channel
your agent which is me proposes to make
outlandish accusations unsupported by
fact or
outlandish we r and if you read the
indictment that summary
of what happened with brody it's to a t
what we were already looking at it's
crazy
we write again today to demand that you
cease and dismiss assist your unlawful
harassment
of and threatening behavior toward mr
brody his public relations relations
agent nathan miller
and his associates your employees and
agents have employed intimidating and
unlawful tactics in what you purport to
be a reporting operation
including the legal taping of
conversations with mr level and mr
miller
and use of hacked materials in illegally
taped conversations that you proposed
disclosed with untruthful commentary
this conduct makes you clear that you
are not a legitimate media organization
but rather agents for hire masquerading
as media oh agents were higher that's
not as cool that's not
no it's mercenary we are we are we will
be contacting youtube to seek removal of
any content about mr broad and produced
by your organization oh
this might get removed to begin your
ostensible editor reporter rocco castoro
expressed surprise that his calls and
emails to me and my law firm are
returned by nathan miller even though
in your signature you've got a number
and an email and i haven't
i've already emailed mr brody about the
questions i didn't hear back from anyone
i'm sorry you know i'm recording why is
he why is he emailing like what is it
what
i don't know because because he told us
that first email that we had documents
that have not been reported on or
that no one other reporters so these
documents what's what sounds like
the most pressing thing i think is that
you know
there are compromised people all over
the us yes and like what levels of
government
in industries hollywood government media
public private sector
i mean it makes sense but like who are
they so i'll put it this way i've had
about 10 individuals
some of them very high powered uh since
i've left vice do things that were
very very inexplicable and you know i've
been called a conspiracy theorist all my
life
well i get to maybe perhaps prove that
some of these individuals
were doing things that were very weird
and i have documentation over the years
and imagine someone like me having proof
that you tried to
do something tricky with me so you guys
know about like the accusations against
epstein
like what he was doing with the island
basically filming people and then being
like
guess what yeah and then also they
started buying them that's nothing new
yeah right
right is is it something similar like
you got a bunch of really wealthy
powerful people and people in industry
no it's more like you took dirty money
and we didn't tell you it's it's the
same and that like just
epstein could you film you with a just a
girl that looked
underage and leveraged that against you
or he could procure you know it's it
goes all
you're radioactive at that point right
yeah sure yeah so what does that mean
for this country
it's it's very scary and it's something
people need to start talking about and
and figuring out amongst themselves is
there anything we can unite over it's
like
foreign influence should not be anywhere
near us in this regard and the scale is
so big it's too big to fail
does it impact our elections uh yes for
certain uh i don't think it impacts
voting machines and i don't think it
results in what you
it's very carefully crafted because
again it's not
in the u.s has done studies on this that
no one including the media talks about
about
uh sorry chinese russia relations for
cyber crime which makes sense why
wouldn't they collaborate on cyber right
now
like why wouldn't they so people need to
start looking at through an
international
lens versus a domestic lens thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all next time
you